every election we know  features some illegality and  irregularity and of course  that's unacceptable i support  strong state-led voting reforms last  year's bizarre  pandemic procedures must not become  the new norm but my colleagues nothing  before us  proves illegality anywhere  near the massive scale  the massive scale that would have  tipped the entire election  nor can public doubt alone  justify a radical break  when the doubt itself  was incited without any evidence  the constitution gives us here in  congress a limited role  we cannot simply declare ourselves a  national  board of elections on steroids  the voters the courts  and the states have all spoken  they've all spoken  if we overrule them it would damage our  republic  forever